hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the
semi-finals of the fide World Cup it is
also the first game that finished the
Magnus Carlsen vs ninjat abasova and for
those of you who are just tuning in uh
ninjat abbasov is uh well having the
tournament of his life he eliminated so
many strong players here he uh
eliminated Peter svidler Anish giri
Lawrence for uh fresnay he eliminated
Salim Salah he defeated uh vedith in the
previous round he just you know crushes
everyone in the previous round Magnus
defeated gookish and he did it also in
classical chess and now yeah it's time
for uh for the azerbaijani Grand Master
to prove himself against the highest
rated player in the world Magnus Carlsen
and even though he started the
tournament at 26-32 rating uh in the
live ratings he's already very close to
2700 So that's just how strong he's
playing this tournament not gonna spoil
too much already you can see in the
title that a lot has happened here let's
check it out it is Magnus with the white
pieces and he opens with Ponte E4 avasov
replies with Pawn to C5 he goes for to
Sicilian Defense we have Knight F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 Magnus
doesn't go for the open he goes for the
inesh Medina the rosholimo attack we
have E6 and now Bishop captures on C6
the early trade we have B captures
uh and pawn to B3 preparing The Thinker
to the dark Square Bishop we have D6 and
now Pawn to E5 and now look at this D
captures on E5 and there are a lot of
games that reach this position where
Knight captures and E5 was played it's a
fairly standard move here uh grishuk had
it against a job of also McShane had it
against her job of an opponent she had
it against moisenko so it has been
played in top chest but everyone always
captured the pawn here but not Magnus
Magnus just plays Pawn to D3 and he says
you are welcome to try and defend your
pawn and you will play this game with
two uh sets of doubled pawns the C pawn
and the E Pawn and of course it is now
as of move uh six that we have a
completely new game I don't know if you
if you're realizing the pattern here but
pretty much in every game that we're
covering from the feeder World Cup
players are finding ingenious ways of
entering new territory very very early
on in the game sometimes even as early
as like move four so here Pawn to F6
abbasov accepts the challenge he says I
will defend my E4 E5 Pawn let's see yeah
let's see you you fight against this
okay Knight B to D2 the Knight now has
excellent outposts on e4 and on C4 so
this is uh in my opinion and obviously
if Magnus plays it in his opinion uh
worth the pawn sacrifice because the
Knight will have an eternal outpost on
C4 there is no B Pawn or D Pawn that can
kick the Knight away from C4 and also if
you put it on e4 uh also there's no deep
on and there's no F Pawn okay there is
the F Pawn on F6 but if you advance it
to F5 then already you weaken your
Center so okay night stage six abusive
now wants to put the Knight on F7 then
it can come to D6 and Magnus goes Rook
to G1 now what what is this he's playing
G4 G5 obviously uh Bishop to A6 and now
Pawn to G4
not really worried about his King's
safety Knight to F7 and now Queen the EQ
with Bishop to E7 and now Bishop to B2
nicely thinking the bishop like nothing
is happening also might be preparing
Queen side castles and here Queen to A5
pinning the Knight here and how do you
continue this position well Magnus went
for the early C4 now if you ask our good
friend the super engine what might you
do here it gives a very similar idea
only through a different move order the
engine says let's play Pawn to G5 first
and the engine justifies this by saying
that okay once black makes a move
regardless of what it is Knight to D6
now you Castle Queen side and if black
Castle's Queen side now you play let's
say Pawn to H4 and after let's say queen
captures an A2 black can or maybe
doesn't have to capture on A2 doesn't
really matter the point is that white
will play C4 and this is the point of
the position uh the Double C Pawn the
the
opponent C4 really logs them down here
the bishop here becomes useless and that
there's not all that much for black to
do here there is no way to reach the
white king white is very safe here and
white will have a very comfortable game
and Magnus says I don't need to do this
Magna says I can just play C4 as well
Magnus disagrees with the engine uh we
have Pawn to G5 here now it's a little
bit different and now Magnus plays Pawn
to H4 we have Pawn to H6 and now Rook
back to H1 by Magnus we have castles
Queen side and castles Queen side so a
similar position has occurred here but
not quite the same and here we have
Queen to C7 by yeah and Magnus goes
Knight to E4 and here again uh the the
idea is fairly obvious you want to go
after the C 5.1 put the queen to E3 and
the Knight on e4 and then you go after
the C5 pawn and the Magnus does it
immediately by playing Knight to the E4
also possible here is the very strong
age captures in G5 and now if H captures
and G5 you play Queen to E4 and only now
after let's say the queen gets it down
back the knights the D6 you play Queen
to E3 and now you're gonna bring the at
night the Knight E4 because now Queen E3
comes with Tempo the Knight attacking
the queen a queen moves and the c51 is
now undefended so the Knight needs to
move for the bishop to defend the pawn
and now Knights the E4 goes after the
pawn so now this is another way to do it
Magnus again chooses a different move
order he plays Knights the E4 first uh
and now uh a queen to E3 can definitely
come as the next move but now he is not
a quite in time G captures an H4 Knight
captures an H4 and now Rook H to G8 just
putting pressure on that G4 Pawn so if
you if you pile up on the C5 Pawn you
still have to defend your G4 pawn and
the situation the clock is 57 minutes
for Magnuson 39 minutes for nijat in the
Magnus uh here after Rook hdg strikes
with Pawn to F4 and okay e captures an
F4 you do not want to see F5 on the
board e captures on F4 and now Knight
captures on F6 at Bishop captures on F6
and first Queen captures an E6 with
check King to B8 and now Queen captures
on F6 and now you have this position
where yeah okay uh We've equalized the
material and Magnus grabbed the pawn
back uh but the black now remains uh
with this double C Pawn so if anyone is
better here it is definitely Magnus
however this gives an Egypt an
opportunity to bring his Bishop back
into the game and now Rook D to E1 he
doesn't care of course about the d-pawn
uh well you could capture it then you
have to worry about something like a
rook to E7 attacking the queen and the
Knight and then of course you lose
material so instead Rook to D6 chases
away the queen and now Queen captures an
F4 Rook captures on G4 that's why the
bishop came to C8 also uh the bishop and
E6 was pretty much useless Queen to E3
and now Rook the E6 I put pressure on
the queen queen back to D2 and now just
Knight the E5 and yes uh it's uh it's
you know maybe not as good a position as
Magnus is but you know uh maybe only
only visually because the C pawns while
are very ugly it does create a wall and
maybe even an impenetrable one for
magnets to cross look at this how do you
how do you attack the black king through
this and okay King to C2 Magnus wants to
improve the safety of his King with King
to B7 ninja does the same and now Rook
to E3 uh adds per uh additional
protection to the V3 Pawn also if you if
you ever want in the future you can even
double up on the e-file uh 23 minutes
for Magnus and 17 minutes for an Egypt
and they are only at move 28 they need
to make 12 more moves to reach time
control so here we have Queen to E7
doubling up on the E file also by
playing uh King to C2 you don't have to
worry about some nasty discoveries with
Knight to D3 check and now Knight to F5
Magnus attacks the queen here Queen to
G5 and now we have Bishop captures on E5
look at this bishop captures on E5
uh and now Rook the G2 attacks magnus's
Queen here Magnus has to defend with
Rook D2 and only now in Egypt trades
Rook captures an EQ Queen captures and
queen captures on F5 and it seems that
the material is going down and the game
should fizzle out to a draw however
let's see what happened we have Rook to
H5 attacking the queen this also
indirectly defends the bishop here yeah
because of course if you play Rook
captures here then just Queen captures
and of course now white is completely
winning if you capture the network Rook
against Bishop completely winning so
after Rook H5 ninja just goes back Queen
to F7 and now look at this we have Queen
to H2 by Magnus and by playing Queen to
H2 Magnus actually blunders the game now
it's not easy to spot why but you guys
are of course uh you know comfortable in
your own homes or maybe driving a car so
feel free to pause the video and find a
win a win for an Egypt while I give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on taking down former
classical world champion Magnus Carlsen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Queen to F uh Queen
to F1 that's the move and the idea is a
very tricky one uh because after Queen
to F1 uh White is without a move there
is no move you can play here and it's
just uh let's take a rook captures on H6
of course we're gonna capture Rook
captures Queen captures and now just a
nice Queen to eat to check picks up the
bishop and you're gonna be up a piece uh
simple as that and other moves don't
really help you if you play something
like Queen to D2 you try to help out
with the defense now comes Rook to G6
and now there is no defense against Rook
to G1 and you're just gonna go after the
white king look at this it's a pretty
funky line Rook to H2 of course you want
to stop the rule coming to the second
rank but now the rule comes to the first
rank also you had to defend against Ru
G2 this would just win the White Queen
Rook G1 and now after Bishop to B2 uh it
doesn't really matter what you have to
play something there's always Queen to
B1 check King to C3 and now Bishop to F5
and look at this the bishop is attacking
the D3 Pawn the queen is attacking the
D3 pawn and that's pretty much it Rook
is coming to D1 and then three pieces
will be attacking the D3 Pawn you will
start capturing and White's position
completely falls apart so that's what an
Egypt miss here and Magnus missed it as
well uh or the other way around Magnus
missed it unfortunately for an Egypt he
missed it as well and he played a rook
the G6 and okay Magnus gets a second
least on life he plays Bishop to F4 now
puts pressure on the H6 Rook H6 Pawn
here and Rook to F6 pressuring the
bishop and just Bishop to E3 now
stopping Rook to F2 we have Bishop to F5
uh now with some potential ideas of
maybe even sacrificing the bishop on D3
but now Magnus plays Bishop captures on
C5 and now uh here you have to play Rook
the E6 Rook the E6 comes with a very
nasty idea of playing Bishop to G4
attacking The Rook uh also at uh eyeing
the E2 square and then just drop being
The Rook to E2 so it's uh magnets would
have to slow down stop his attack and
try to defend his own King but here
ninja plays uh Queen to G6 he puts
pressure on the D3 pawn and now Magnus
just a very nicely Place King to C3 he
sidesteps this he says all right this is
not a very interesting Pawn if you
capture my Pawn here with Bishop
captures I'm just gonna play Bishop
captures on A7 and this is pretty much a
game over there's no way too
I actually continue this because now The
Rook has entrance to the queen side also
the queen has very easy entrance
especially if you capture the bishop
this would be completely winning for
white so instead after King to C3 Rook
the E6 is played but this also doesn't
help as here we have rooked the H4 and
believe it or not again Magnus blunders
uh not magnets but again a position is
blundered by playing the instant Rook to
each H4 it gives Magnus a very good
position and both of them are very low
on time they still need to make two more
moves to reach time control of the
bishop captures an A7 here is just
absolutely crushing now okay King
captures an A7 otherwise you you have
nothing uh is just a game over Queen to
F2 with check nicely connect with the
bishop and you're gonna be down to pawns
King B7 Rook captures here and two extra
Pawns of course completely winning so
instead after rookie 6 Rook the H4 was
played by Magnus uh but now uh of course
you can come back into the game Bishop
to G4 this is move 39 One More Moon
needs to be made and uh into F4 is
objectively the best move but Magnus
plays Bishop captures on A7 now and this
is a winning for Magnus unless unless an
idiot finds a move that ruins his plans
and forces a draw so this is a big one
this is a really really big one try to
find the only move that doesn't lose the
game from Egypt while I give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh being a an
excellent defender of uh almost
indefensible positions And for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is a queen to G7 with check which is
very very close to what Ninja actually
played he played Queen to F6 with check
but it's important to play Queen to G7
check because you defend the seventh
rank now you can play pretty much
whatever you want doesn't really matter
you can go to B4 you can go to the
bishop to attack the queen but point is
after Kingdom before you can actually
capture the bishop because now Queen to
C7 is not an option and if you go back
with Bishop to D4 yes this is possible
but still just Queen to G5 and now the
queen gets access to the C1 square and
that's enough for for black to hold the
draw however after Bishop captures an A7
he didn't play Queen to G7 with check he
played Queen to F6 with the check and it
looks the same but it just doesn't
control the seventh rank or more
specifically the the C 7 square and now
Magnus is completely winning he plays
King to B4 now one way ninja could have
solved this position is if he just uh
you know thought to himself am I paying
enough attention to the B4 square if he
thought that then he would have found
Queen to G7 but he didn't that you know
what are you gonna do and now the
problem is if of course a king captures
an A7 then just Queen to C7 check that's
it and after King to A8 you can play
whatever you want real characters on G4
liar threatening Rook to G8 and of
course if Queen to fade with check you
can just move the king now next you're
gonna play uh Rook to G7 Checkmate the
black king whatever you play here of
course everything is completely winning
so ninja tried one last idea Rook the E5
hoping that Magnus goes for the bishop
with King captors uh A7 but of course
Magnus doesn't he plays Pawn to D4 and
now he's completely safe he doesn't care
what Ninja plays because whatever he
plays even a check you know will be met
with C5 and The Rook will still be
hanging so he will always be a Tempo up
doesn't matter what does he did play
Queen to E7 with check Magnus played
Pawn to C5 and he was in this position
animal 43 that ninja abaso resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the point is there's nothing
for you to play next move You're Gonna
Lose The Rook uh so you could maybe
capture the bishop and then give up the
Rogue but that's pretty much pointless
and the the real problem is if you move
the
uh Rook let's say you play this you
defend the bishop just Queen to B8 with
the check if the Rook moves you allow
the queen into the mating net the queen
king day six and queen to B6 will be
Checkmate so there is no move here only
move you can play after a C5 is like
like I said this and then D captures an
E5 also the pawn is protected there is
absolutely nothing here for black
absolutely nothing okay you can trap The
Rook a little bit for for the moment but
the queen will move you can get the Rook
into the game uh you can put the Rook
behind the past pawn it doesn't really
matter where Rook H1 Rook D1 uh yeah
there's no counter play here so of
course he just saw this after C5 he
resigned the game he congratulated
Magnus and now he will have the white
pieces in the next game if he can take
down Magnus Carlsen then he will be able
to force tie breaks if not it will be
Magnus Carlsen in the finals waiting for
the winner of the match pragnananda
versus Fabiano caruana that is still
being played the first game that's still
being played while I'm recording this so
I will keep you guys informed uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
that stuff
he had he had a win against Magnus here
after Magnus uh you know carelessly
plays the queen on H2 he had Queen to F1
but again you trust Magnus is the Magnus
effect many have fallen victim to it and
uh now he joins the ranks uh so yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Selena was
kashyap bullet just thriller.com Gustav
Adolfo Chaves Michael shui and yunyang
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video World Cup until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day